soiron lyster dignac merci d'être avec
nous tout d'abord cette décision du
conseil d'état ce qu'on peut parler
vraiment de camoufler pour le
gouvernement
oui bien sûr c'est un petit camouflet
ça veut dire qu'une fois de plus le
gouvernement a proposé un décret qui
n'était pas satisfaisant sur le point de
vue technique et le conseil d'état ne
l'a tout de suite remarqué donc ça
couvin que l'amateurisme du gouvernement
dans cette opération
alors à relativiser peut-être en tout
cas pour la ministre du travail et des
abbesses bande qui dit le conseil d'état
nous demande d'attendre encore un peu et
censure uniquement la date d'entrée en
vigueur ça veut dire quoi concrètement
il faut s'attendre à voir une autre
réforme
ça veut dire d'abord que le conseil
d'état a saisi après une décision
d'urgence à la décision d'urgence
c'est de suspendre la date de mise en
oeuvre de la réforme
le conseil d'état a remarqué que la
réforme frappé les chômeurs à partir du
1er juillet alors que les entreprises
qui étaient censés être incités à offrir
des emplois à temps plein la réforme
entrée en vigueur le 1er septembre 2022
peut poser des tas a considéré par
ailleurs la situation du marché du
travail n'était pas bonne
donc il a demandé l'imposer au
gouvernement de retarder le le montant
de l'alloeu la date de mise en oeuvre de
la réforme est par ailleurs
par ailleurs le conseil d'état a dit que
la l'examiner sur le fond le contenu de
la réforme
il est donc que c'est une lame c'est un
rasoir à deux lames la première lame
vient de frapper la seconde ça sera dans
quelques mois
alors vous l'avez dit vous-même à une
mesure d'urgence et un juge des référés
veux dire clairement que mettre en place
cette réforme dans cette période
d'incertitude professionnel ça mettait
en danger
beaucoup de nos concitoyens l'économiste
que vous êtes est d'accord avec ce
diagnostic du juge oui bien sûr puisque
la réforme comme on l'a dit à maintes
reprises elle et aboutir à faire qu au
secundo il y avait environ 1,2 million
de chômeurs à venir qu'ils allaient
perdre environ 17% de leurs allocations
sachant que ce sont des allocations de
près gère donc des allocations déjà très
faible on a des gens qui normalement
auraient touché 850 euros par mois qui
se retrouvaient devoir toucher 600 euros
par mois ce qui était vraiment très peu
ton que le conseil d'état ait considéré
que le fait de faire baisser à ce point
les allocations chômage n'allait pas
permettre en aucune façon à ces
personnes de trouver un emploi que votre
âme à ce que disaient les chômeurs ne se
choisissent pas d'être dans des
situations précaires et les chômeurs ne
peuvent pas aller voir leurs plantes
wire en leur disant va vous savez je ne
touche de 600 euros par mois si je suis
chômeur donc fait boire un emploi à
temps plein c'est pas comme ça que ça
joue au niveau du marché du travail
alors l'exécutif mais affirme que le
système actuel favorise ce qui altère
son contrat courrait une activité au
contraire d
et des contrats longue durée est ce que
c'est c'est réellement le cas selon vous
bien sûr c'est pas c'est pas le cas le
comme je l'étais les chômeurs n'ont pas
le choix là les chômeurs ne choisissent
pas d'être très clair on a des
professions où effectivement les
employeurs ont pris l'habitude de
proposer des contrats précaires que ce
soit dans le commerce hôtels cafés
restaurants et les chômeurs c'est pas un
choix délibéré des chômeurs il s'en
prendre aux chômeurs ça ne s'en prendre
aux entreprises sans modifier la
législation qui a permis le
développement des contrats courts
c'est vraiment une mesure à la fois
déplaisante et inefficace le
gouvernement affirme justement que cette
réforme permettra ces fameux contrats
courts d'obtenir à terme des contrats
plus longue durée
vous y croyez à cette affirmation
je ne dois absolument je n'y crois
absolument pas assez et comptera comme
vous savez sont décidés opposé par le
patronat et si un personne divin ce
contrat est trop court
il me plaît pas je raconte râlons
patronale du dis bien aucun problème
prenez la porte d'autres bat facilement
quelqu'un pour prendre ce contrat donc
c'est pas du tout à ce niveau là qu'il
faut agir à une fois agir au niveau des
entreprises il faut revenir sur les
différents dispositifs qui ont permis le
développement des contrats courts
le fait qu' on peut on peut faire des
cdd d'usagé dans un certain nombre de
professions c'est au niveau du si au
niveau des entreprises qu'il faut qu'il
faut agir et non pas au niveau des
salariés qui vraiment eux n'ont aucun
n'en a plus d'un quasi totalité des cas
aucun degré de liberté et je répète un
ca
la mesure frappe dit rigueur ça veut
dire des gens qui de toute façon on des
indemnités extrêmement faible et plus le
charme si on peut dire de la réponse
c'est qu'elle est extrêmement compliquée
puisque les précaires devait pour
calculer leurs droits il fallait
remonter
il faut remonter sur deux ans et il faut
pendant deux ans que l'épée terres
deviennent ouvrait les travaux les
salaires qu'ils ont effectivement
effectué c'est pas une réforme qui
simplifie la vie de ces de ces personnes
merci henri sterdyniak économiste mon
des économistes atterrés d'avoir été
avec nous